no I everything's fun and games till
someone gets hurt I will laugh when I'm
nervous I laugh when it's funny I laugh
when I'm mad this one particular time it
was horrible it was so bad I was in a
meeting room there were five of us and
we're having a very serious meeting
talking about video pitches and waste
were gonna go about doing this feature
video we were planning it and someone in
the meeting who farted I felt really
immature cuz I was only one who even
like kind of acknowledge it I just like
you know that snoring was pay attention
they just carried on like adults the
entire time hmm yes and that was yeah
that was the moment that I can clearly
remember because they were tears
streaming down my cheeks and everyone
else is really quiet and like just talk
[Music]
it wasn't funny at the time but I will
say we all laughed uncontrollably after
this happen this is one of my most
embarrassing stories but I hope that you
find some joy out of it I did a lot of
theater whenever I was growing up we
both did and I was in a community
theater production of a little show
called Sue's ago the musical I was
playing a bird in the show named
gertrude mcfuzz she starts out the show
with a very small tail she's not
impressive at all wouldn't know what
that's like in order to impress a man
decides that she needs to grow a very
long tail we had these huge Boas that
were coming from this way out all the
way like offstage it was probably like
what like 20 feet long yours was really
long it was insane like it was out of
control and we should have realized that
this would cause trouble but no one
thinks of that whenever you're just
doing a community theater production
everything's fun and games till someone
gets hurt so I was going on first night
big audience my mom my dad are there
probably the president I don't know if
there's a lot of people there and so I'm
getting ready to go out and do my big
number with a big log tale all of this I
walk out on stage walk down a set of
stairs get to the middle of the stage
and all of a sudden I can't walk anymore
I'm stuck and I can't figure out what's
happening I'm like literally trying to
move forward but you know like those
like slow motion cams that's like what I
looked like but in real life I could not
make any forward progress and my eyes
are terrified I'm looking over at my co
start like I don't know what's happening
yep and then we're all off stage and I'm
just a bird girl in the show we notice
that there's some kind of problem
Karen's not doing anything she's
supposed to be doing on stage we start
to trace where her tail is going
suddenly find out one of the giant fans
that's on stage like keep the stage cool
and things has caught her tail and it's
propellers and now she is stationary
wherever she I have tethered like a
leash it isn't unbelievable and with no
help in sight so I'm singing my song
it's coming to the end and I'm thinking
I don't know where to go I don't know
how to get out of this I can hear
offstage people laughing so this is not
a fun time for me I'm very nervous we're
all cracking up like we can't get enough
of
but we know that something has to happen
so they're talking about potentially
hide and Karen offstage and I'll come in
and make it like a twin moment where we
just pretend I'm the one who's supposed
to be doing it our plan then comes I
will now go under the stage where we
have like these risers and I'm gonna go
under the stage pull her out of the fan
to release her so she can continue on
with the show so we have this huge
backdrop and all you can see because the
lights are pointed directly at it you
see this like shadow of a human which is
me crawling back there trying to get to
the giant fan as Karen's like making up
stuff that doesn't even go in the show
and I could hear people laughing
offstage so I can imagine how crazy this
looks behind me just a shadow of Connie
moving towards the fan to untether me
out of there yeah so I finally got her
out and we lost a few feathers but she
got out and then we finally got off
stage and like right after a few seconds
then everyone in the cast is dying
laughing I think people miss their
entrance and signal on stage this is
just one of those moments you can't
prepare for it you're like that's life
you know sometimes your tail gets stuck
in bands if you can't move anymore I
mean I guess the moral of the story is
like birds of a feather stick together
yeah are like don't impress boys with
long tails
[Music]